all right what would happen if you gave
up all grains
for
two weeks 14 days
that's what we're gonna talk about today
and yes i'm talking about the breads
pasta the cereal the crackers the
biscuits the waffles the pancakes the
muffins the donuts etc etc
as well as the rice and the corn now if
we compare giving up sugar for two weeks
to giving up grains for two weeks i
really think you're gonna have way more
benefit giving up the grains for two
weeks simply because what these grains
do
to your gut not only do you have the
spike in blood sugar but you also have a
lot of inflammation all right let's
unpack this topic what's a grain
well grain is a seed
of
grass okay different types of grass and
in a grain you have three parts you have
the bran
which is the fiber part
which has some b vitamins you also have
the germ part which has some b vitamins
vitamin e
minerals
and
phytonutrients
then you have what's called the
endosperm okay that's where you have all
the carbohydrate
this is where you have some more b
vitamins and this is where you have the
protein and i'm talking about gluten
okay gluten so
very few people
are consuming just straight whole grain
like they don't go and buy this grain
and then come home and
germinate it soak it you know getting
rid of the phytic acid so that way you
don't have something that blocks your
minerals and then they don't
then dry it out and then grind it into
flour right away and then turn into
bread that's not what happens you go to
the store and you either buy the product
that's already done or you might buy
flour and even if it's whole grain or
whole wheat flour it's been sitting on
the shelf for quite some time now the
definition of whole grain is any mixture
of bran endosperm
germ
in proportion one would expect to see
intact grain an fda said if it's at
least 51 percent whole grain it can be
considered or defined as whole grain
so you can basically have 49
refined grain with this whole grain in
its whole grain
so here's the problem
as soon as they grind the grain okay
they expose it to air and light
and oxygen
that right there oxidizes and destroys
the delicate fatty acids
the delicate
vitamins
this is why back in the 20s and 30s and
40s
they started to
fortify grains okay
they started to add
some
so-called nutrients back into the grains
because
quite a few people
were ending up with diseases like
pellegra which is a severe
b3 deficiency uh and beriberi which is a
severe b1 deficiency and i think i
recall a report even in the early 1900s
there were like 7 000 people who died of
pelegra which is the b3 deficiency
because of these grains so they ended up
adding in
um some
synthetic
version of
vitamins back into this grain to try to
bring it back to where it was because in
the refining process you end up
stripping out a lot of nutrition so they
put back in iron b1 b2 b3 folic acid and
calcium and you can imagine the
quality of those vitamins are definitely
probably the lowest list they're made
from petroleum and they just stick them
in there not too impressed with that the
problem is when you eat grains that have
been fortified which
it's mainly in america and other in a
few other countries but certain parts of
uh western europe and i think italy
don't use this fortification crap and so
this is why
when you eat grains in other parts of
the world if you're not in the us
you don't nearly get the bloating the
grain doesn't sit in your gut like a
iron weight because there's iron in
there right plus they do use a different
type of grain as well but that
fortification is not good on your
digestive system so when they actually
refine the grain okay you end up eating
the product
and you actually if you consume refined
grains you create deficiencies of
certain nutrients okay
and at least two of the primary
nutrients that you'll create
deficiencies
are the b vitamins and the vitamin e
complex now
you know they put back in three b
vitamins but what about all the other b
vitamins
these other b vitamins that are not in
there that you then become deficient in
can create a major strain
on your heart
now you may have not heard a vitamin
before
there's some interesting research done
by dr royal lee back in the 1940s and
even 50s but another name for vitamin b4
is adenine is a critical critical
compound in the regulation of
cardiovascular function
both
in the coronary artery
as well as in the
rhythm of the heart the neurological
pacemaker of the heart and so if you're
deficient in this element i could put a
big strain
on not just one part of the heart
several parts of the heart so giving up
grain for two weeks
will take some relief off of your heart
both the coronary artery as well as in
the
pacemaker of the heart so the heart can
then stay in rhythm much easier
now let's talk about vitamin e
as far as the heart goes your vitamin e
is
very necessary to prevent angina
because vitamin e improves the oxygen
carrying capacity of the heart tissue
by up to 250 percent
so if you're deficient
in vitamin e the heart has to labor it
doesn't get enough oxygen and the heart
can even form a heart cramp that's
called angina so when you give up grains
for two weeks you're going to take a big
stress off the heart all right the next
point i'm going to bring up is just the
simple
carbs the refined carbohydrates in these
grains they're huge
with a pretty high glycemic index and
i'm not even talking about the added
sugar to the cereals and all these other
grains just talking about
where grains are on the glycemic index
okay especially refined grains
they are high
so what happens is this grain turns into
sugar very quick it spikes your blood
sugar and now you're going to get all
the bad effects of high insulin and high
blood sugar and that's going to be
weight gain that's going to have
cognitive
problems you're going to be less smart
less focus
less
concentration
you're going to have a lowered mood
you're going to be irritable you're
going to have more anxiety and you're
simply going to be
tired okay other than that you're going
to be totally fine now i just want to
point out
when you consume pasta it's a little bit
different if you check your blood sugars
right after consuming pasta
um
they won't be spiked
it's kind of a delay
apparently pasta is more dense so it
takes a while for it to break down so if
you check it within an hour your blood
sugars will be spiked in a major way so
just because it doesn't get spiked right
away doesn't mean it's not going to
spike
later
all right the next point i want to bring
up is this thing called phytic acid what
is it it's a protective
chemical that seeds use to keep a seed
from sprouting okay
and
when you consume grains with phytic acid
because you didn't
germinate them or soak them okay
what happens is you now are going to
have a difficult time absorbing minerals
like zinc
like iron like calcium
things like that so this is why grains
um inhibit your ability to absorb
minerals trace minerals so by getting
off grains for two weeks guess what no
phytic acid and you finally get to
absorb these wonderful trace minerals
that's going to be cool and there's a
whole
chain reaction of positive things that
are going to happen just from that
all right the next point i want to bring
up is the reduction of gut inflammation
when you stop eating grains why because
of gluten gluten is one of the most
inflammatory things for the gut that you
can consume so many people
have a gluten intolerance okay they just
can't tolerate it or they have a severe
allergy to gluten it's a protein and
even if it doesn't directly affect the
gut it affects other parts of your body
there's a lot information on that i will
put a link down below but it's going to
affect
the pain in your gut it's going to
affect bloating
distension you're going to feel like
you're pregnant after you eat grains
that was me you're going to have pain in
your stomach that was me and anything
that's going on with the gut is going to
be going on with the brain
so if you have gut inflammation guess
what it's going to affect your brain
you're going to have brain fog
you're going to have all sorts of
behavioral issues and mood problems and
anxiety and even depression the list
goes on and on that's not all we got
more
if you don't eat grains
okay there's no fortification so we'll
have less bloating from that you're
going to feel like
oh wow my stomach isn't so bloated now
also grains
are high in omega-6 fatty acids and
those are the things that create
inflammation so guess what you're going
to have a lot less inflammation uh not
just in your colon but through the whole
body so if you have arthritis chances
are that arthritis might actually
disappear all right number eight you're
going to have less
fluid retention
because these are refined grains usually
okay mostly refined grains
refined carbohydrate you're going to
hold a lot of fluid
and so an average person is probably
holding minimally 13 pounds of excess
fluid when they do high carbs so getting
rid of the grains for two weeks you'll
probably lose at least 13 pounds of
fluid that's going to be cool
also you're going to sleep better
there's going to be more hormonal
balance there's going to be less
effect on the neurotransmitters in your
brain like dopamine
and you're going to just feel calmer
you're going to feel stress free okay
and then you're going to sleep better
also and this is interesting
if you have hashimoto's which is usually
the most common form of hypothyroidism
okay 90 of people that have
hypothyroidism have hashimoto's
you definitely need to get off grains
immediately why because the gluten
in the
grain the protein
can mimic the thyroid
and cause what's called
molecular mimicry where your immune
system is attacking
the thyroid simply because
you're eating gluten okay
so you need to get rid of that and guess
what your thyroid is going to be a lot
happier and that's going to lead to a
whole cascade of wonderful things from
just from that
also
all this inflammation that you have is
going to go away and your immune system
will now finally get a chance to work
much better you're going to be running
less on glucose and more in ketones and
so you're going to have a cleaner fuel
and your immune system loves that so
you'll be less sick as well and lastly
you're going to be
less exposed to something called
glyphosate
glyphosate is the thing they spray
grains unfortunately even though
some of these grains are not even gmo
they still spray them
less glyphosate means lower risk of
cancer and it also means better
digestive
health because the glyphosate kills
microbes and they can affect your gi as
well so i challenge you
to give up grains
for two weeks and then write down in the
comments section how wonderful your life
is
because of that
now if you haven't seen my other video
on giving up sugar for two weeks i put
it right here check it out